hey youtubers is Charlie since season
four is over and a lot of you guys have
requested history stuff from the books I
thought it'd be fun to do a bonus video
for Aegon the first Aegon the conquerer
so far in the books and on the show he's
the most famous member of their house to
ever live Daenerys is kind of polarizing
and that you know either love her or you
hate her character her destiny is still
fairly unwritten so it remains to be
seen whether or not she's going to
become the most famous person of their
house but if you just finding me for the
first time I'm doing Game of Thrones
bonus videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything a lot of
times I'll pick topics based on things
that you guys suggest so feel free to
suggest anything you guys want to learn
more about in the comments and I'm doing
a special giveaway that I'll explain
after I get done with the history video
so who is Aegon the first and why is he
so much more important than the other
hundreds of Targaryens that followed him
though the answer is he's largely
associated with the war of conquest
that's a span of time when Aegon gave
the Andal rulers of Westeros and
Ultimatum bend the knee or you get the
dragons that's why he's known as Aegon
the conquerer he conquered the six
kingdoms of Westeros didn't quite
conquer dorm but they were brought in
much later the Iron Throne is made from
thousands of melted down swords of those
Andals he defeated on the show the
throne is way smaller so it's harder to
tell originally george RR martin
described it as being this big it's so
huge just because there's so many swords
it's not practical for television which
is why we see the smaller version that's
the CliffsNotes
but recently george RR martin has
published a lot more backstory for the
Targaryens around this time around the
time a Khan was alive so starting off
all the way in the beginning 12 years
before the doom of Valyria and around
114 BC that's before conquest in our
Targaryen who was the head of the
household at that time moved everything
of theirs to Dragonstone after one of
his daughters Danice had a vision of the
doom and whenever I say everything he
moved all their wealth all the dragons
all the servants like literally
everything they had if you've ever
thought about events repeating
themselves in A Song of Ice and Fire
the Eastern continent around the
Valyrian freehold was known as the lands
of the long summer before the doom right
now on the show the long summer is just
now ending in Westeros that's why you
keep hearing winter is coming it's a
metaphor for the end of prosperity but
unlike the Targaryen there are very few
people fleeing Westeros right now
Dragonstone up to the
oome had been the westernmost outpost of
the Valyrian freehold and it served as a
heavily defensible point where the
Dragonlords could control trade around
Blackwater Bay that's that area around
King's Landing but at this point it
became the permanent home of the
Targaryen so about five generations
passed before Aegon the conquerer was
born those around about a hundred years
his birth date is recorded as 27 BC
before conquest so he wasn't quite 30
before he began the war he was the
middle child his older sister was named
Visenya and his younger sister was named
Reynes even though it was customary to
marry brother to sister in old Valyria
Aegon supposedly also married his
younger sister ran as out of lust in the
older one out of responsibility at the
time of his birth they only had three
dragons whenever they flipped from
Valyria to Dragonstone they had five but
only balerion the black dread survived
so far right now none of the literature
has explained why those other four
dragons died only that balerion survived
in the years between their landing in a
gods birth two more dragons were hatched
Veigar and myrrh axes those were the
dragons that his sister's road while he
was growing up Aegon visited Westeros a
couple times he didn't just land there
whenever he was starting the war he even
had that massive table at Dragonstone
constructed the one with the
topographical map of Westeros that's
probably one of the most famous
non-magical antiques in the Seven
Kingdoms next to the iron throne itself
so the war of conquest actually started
because of another war that was going on
arghhhh elect the ruler in the
Stormlands wanted help defeating hair in
the black who was actually ruling the
area kind of round King's Landing in the
north in exchange for his help he
offered Aegon his daughter in marriage
and a bunch of their land but Aegon was
already married to his two sisters so he
turned down the proposal and countered
by offering his help in exchange for all
the land actually even more land like a
ton more land and the marriage of our
Galax daughter to Egan's childhood
friend
orys baratheon so now you kind of see
where house Baratheon was born they were
elevated to lordship during the war of
conquest they basically took over the
Stormlands
after our collect that proposal of
Aegon's back in his face he pulled the
reek thing wherever he sent pieces of a
God's messenger back to him in a box
Aegon then decided to make war on all
the Andal kings that was basically the
official start of the war
Qwest or whenever he decided to make war
on them the way the calendars work on
the show right now BC before conquest
and Al after landing referred to when he
first landed right here at the black
rush the place where he would eventually
build King's Landing
that's generally regarded as the start
date of the war it took about two full
years after that to completely subdue
the six kingdoms not including Dorne so
technically you could look at it as you
know there being two years between BC
and Al it's a little fuzzy the Kings
that he defeated included torrents start
kicking the north Ronald Aaron king of
the Vale his mother was actually regent
for him just like Circe was regent for
Joffrey because he was a really young
boy Harun hor king of the Iron Islands
in the Riverlands loren lannister king
of the westerland's Mern gardener king
of the reach and Argyll actor and n't
kang of the Stormlands so he didn't just
you know fly the dragons in right away
and defeat everyone one by one he
actually sustained heavy losses which is
why the war took over two years and even
then he still couldn't defeat the
Martel's in Dorne by the end of the war
though some of the Kings had honorably
bent the knee like the Starks and the
Aaron's and the rest were smashed or
melted in battle you know big dragons
remember I can't remember if they
mentioned it on the show but the kings
that actually bent the knee to a god did
not get their swords melted down into
the iron throne so like there is no
stark sword in the Iron Throne however
as a season 4 episode 1 Tywin Lannister
melted down Ned Stark's foolery and
blade ice because he was silent during
that scene it's hard to tell if he was
thinking about that historical fact
about there being no stark blade that
had been melted down in the Iron Throne
it seems like something that Tywin would
be stuck on even though it happened
hundreds of years before he was born
the defeat of the Lannisters during the
war conquest was really cool towards the
end of the war before he marched on door
and Aegon met the Lannisters in the
Gardiners in battle they had formed an
alliance instead of starting an all-out
ground assault Aegon had the dragon set
the whole field of grass on fire
wherever the enemy was they flipped
their and surrendered immediately
it's just a good example of
sophisticated use of dragons in battle
you know instead of having the Dragons
just pick people off one at a time they
just turn the heat up in the oven much
more efficient but right now on the show
I don't think that Daenerys has the
dragon lore to attempt something like
this
plus in the desert all the land has
already been burnt to a crisp so it's
not quite as effective eventually the
survivors of the war of conquest
confirmed Aegon as king in old town but
instead of building his new city there
he decided to build it around his old
fort it was called Aegon fort it was
basically where the Red Keep would
eventually be after living in Aegon fort
for a little while Aegon decided that it
was basically a shitty castle so he
moved back to Dragonstone and had a much
nicer one built that eventually became
the red keep it basically took the rest
of his life to finish building the red
keep though and when I say the red keep
I mean the entire castle I'm not just
talking about maegor's holdfast the
other places that were built to Aegon
specifications include the Queen's
ballroom the maiden vault the white
sword tower that's where the Kingsguard
lived the Great Hall traders walk and
four different levels of dungeons all
the way down to the black cells
that's the lowest area of the dungeon
wherever Tyrion was when Jaime helped
him escape we've seen pretty much all
the other areas of the castle on the
show we mostly see the throne room but
we were in the white sword tower
whenever Jaime and Cersei were humping
their brains out and don't forget the
Tower of the hand of the king that's
where ever Tywin's offices were Aegon
died about 37 years after he was
confirmed as king so he was about in his
mid-60s but there aren't really any
details about how he died or you know
his succession plan but his son by
Rainey's took office his name was Inez
the first it caused a bit of a scandal
the Church of the seven flipped out
whenever he took office because they saw
him as a son born out of incest it led
to the first faith militant uprising
that's the army of the Church it's just
like a regular army but they take orders
from the church Aegon son was about
thirty whenever he took office but he
only lived for about five years after
that so that's a somewhat abridged
version of Aegon the conquerors history
George our Martin is publishing a book
called world of Ice and Fire this fall
so hopefully that will have new
historical information to add some more
context to all this so I'm not going to
be doing a Q&A for this video just
because Teen Wolf starts tomorrow night
now I'll be doing videos for that but I
am doing a special new giveaway I'm
going to be giving away copies of the
books to one person per Game of Thrones
video I'll just be picking winners
randomly from the comments all you have
to do to participate is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
let's starting with this video right
here so all you have to do is just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
I'll announce the winner next week
whenever I post my next game of Thrones
bonus video so I'll just do this for
like the next six or seven weeks and see
how it goes and if it goes well and you
guys like it I'll just keep doing it so
the prize is just going to be your
choice of one of the books either a
Kindle edition or paperback it's open to
international people too so no worries
so feel free to ask me any questions
about Aegon the Conqueror or the contest
but right now click here to get my top
10 moments from season four and click
here to learn about my season 5
predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives